Can a specific person be represented?
What do you think of a particular person s manifestation?
Listen these are questions
that I get so often
I talked about it a little bit here.
Let's talk about it again.
because why not
Can a specific person be represented?
Listen of course
that you can because
that there are no rules
They tell us what we can
What cannot be manifested
Everything can and everything is possible.
As for the manifestation
What do I think about this kind of manifestation?
I will tell you that I think
that 99 percent
This kind of manifestation is simply complete.
a waste of time and immediately marked
not because there is something wrong with this manifestation
or with this desire
because there are no stupid or wrong desires
and there are no stupid or wrong manifestations
the point is that Just the most common people
who have this kind of desire
EE or are involved in such manifestations at all
are not completely ready
for these demonstrations
I usually listen to these stories.
when we want to manifest this particular person
it seems to us
that we do it for love
but really this
What is happening in us right now
It has absolutely nothing to do with love.
when we want to express a specific person
we usually hang on to this manifestation
Fingers around the neck of the person
and Simply
as if we produce such a mass of tension
around this whole situation
that I just really
Nothing can happen here.
I have no idea if there are such people in the world.
who are able to manifest a specific person
Without this tension
without looking
every movement of this person.
without observation looked
not looked
did not reply to SMS
wrote back after 5 hours
What does it mean or I don't know
She didn't look at me during the,
uh, party.
But when we met at the store
She talked to me.
Wants me or doesn't want me
will he come back to me
Will he come back to me?
he said.
that he doesn't want me
But I see How he looks at me
so maybe he will come back
Listen up.
these stories Simply
are totally absurd
and I think
that each of us was in this type of stories and I think
that we all know them well
Just this 1
the only person becomes our object of desire
It's just this person
is able to
give us happiness
you feel here at all
it starts to be mega-crooked
As for the manifestation
No one else is important to me.
I just want him
I only want her I only want them
No one else but them
The tension at the moment
is taking place throughout this manifestation
this is just some
Total Total Action
and listen the greater the tension
the bigger the problem with letting go
This manifestation
this result
this person all this story
and listen at the same time
The bigger the problem we have with letting go
the more we should understand
that we should let go
because
This one
This inability to let go
It just means that
is at all so
it's all clamped
and we can be absolutely sure
from this manifestation of ours
Nothing will come out
or at least nothing good will come out
because if clamping
suddenly a manifestation will appear in our reality
We can be sure
that this is some mega-grand manifestation
because she is
a reflection of our tightening
Okay,
what to do.
let go dear
Stop these demonstrations
Let go of this result
Let go of these relationships and take care of yourself.
take care of self-love
take care of your well-being
Take care of putting yourself in first place
take care of yourself
take care of working on yourself
to become a person
which can have
The love of your dreams in your life
When we let go
in our space immediately
appears very
a lot of space
and we are working on ourselves
We are entering a completely new level
wibracyjno-energetyczny
We become a completely new version of ourselves.
and listen if
your chosen one
Your chosen ones live
At this level wibracyjno-energetycznym
They will appear in your life.
If they don t appear in your life at the time.
in which you stand in the fullness of your power
When you take care of yourself
when you love each other
When you feel worthy of the best
It simply means in the world
that they are not for you
The Best Option
are not an option that just fits the place
where you are and to you
They are not an option that serves you.
listen
just letting go of the whole story and working on myself
You will be sure
This manifestation
which you focus on
It is simply something
What is best for you at the moment
because at the moment
when we are fixated on this manifestation
It's us.
We lose awareness of this
what is really happening here
we do not see
We do not see clearly
What this situation really is
In this connection
to really see what's going on
We just need to take a step back.
we have to take care of ourselves
and at this moment
We will always be clear